leur public sénat bonjour à tous merci
de nous retrouver sur public sénat à
suivre cet après-midi sur notre antenne
à la déclaration du gouvernement sur le
programme de stabilité pour 2013 2017
le programme de stabilité doit préciser
comment le gouvernement entend ramener
les finances publiques sous la barre des
3%
rappelons qu'en 2012 le déficit public
de la france était de 4,8 pour cent du
pib et que la france comme cinq autres
pays de l'union européenne à dieu
demandé un délai supplémentaire pour se
conformer aux objectifs de 3%
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre ce débat bonne
après midi à tous
la parole est à monsieur v sort de
l'année pour rappel au règlement oui
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais intervenir effectivement
sur un rappel au règlement sur le
fondement de l'article 47 bis nous
apprêtons aujourd'hui à entendre une
déclaration du gouvernement relative à
la présentation prochaine du programme
de stabilité pour les années 2013 à 2017
à la commission européenne
cette déclaration faite sur le fondement
de l'article 50 1 permet au gouvernement
de soumettre sa déclaration à un vote
sans incidence quant à sa responsabilité
politique devant le parlement
la même déclaration que vous allez nous
présenter aura fait l'objet d'un vote à
l'assemblée messieurs les ministres mais
sera refusée au sénat or cette même
déclaration préfigure voix représente
considérablement les débats que nous
aurons à l'automne prochain
lors de la discussion du projet de loi
de finances initiale pour 2014 l'article
47 bis de notre règlement impose de
scrutin public sur la première partie de
la loi de finances et le vote solennel
sur l'ensemble de la loi en ne
soumettant pas votre programme de
stabilité à notre vote vous bafouer
l'esprit de la loi organique de
programmation ou bafouer l'esprit de
notre règlement et surtout vous bafouez
les prérogatives du sénat en matière de
contrôle beach budgétaire le plus
terre qui soit cette attitude est
symptomatique du manque de confiance du
gouvernement envers la représentation
nationale et à ce titre je voudrais
reprendre les déclarations qui ont été
faites ici même par le premier ministre
jean marc ayrault le 4 juillet dernier
2012 les travaux et les contributions du
sénat qui d'ailleurs rejoignent très
souvent les priorités du gouvernement
doivent être pour notre action une
source d'inspiration constante
je m'engage ici disait il à l'époque
aujourd'hui associer les représentants
du parlement le plus en amont possible
pour préparer les grandes décisions du
gouvernement
c'est à mon avis la bonne manière de
procéder pour renforcer le rôle et les
droits du parlement
alors vous en conviendrez messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues de deux
choses l'une soit le gouvernement
considère que ce qui la déclaration qui
nous fait aujourd'hui n'est pas une
grande décision
et dans ces cas là je comprends qu'il
puisse ne pas être soumis au vote et
qu'elle ne fasse pas l'objet d'une
association plus importantes du sénat
soit 100 et une ce que je que je crois
et à ce moment là le premier ministre ne
respecte pas l'engagement qu'ils avaient
pris ici même devant nous ce que je
trouve très grave
alors cette décision de non votre montre
d'abord l'absence de confiance du
gouvernement
la représentation nationale une
dévalorisation du sénat un problème de
crédibilité aussi de ce programme de
stabilité parce que ce programme de
stabilité serait d'autant plus fort
qu'eux il sera approuvé par l'ensemble
du parlement français et je crois que
pour la commission européenne ça sera un
élément fort et sur le fond il ya un
vrai problème de crédibilité de ce
programme qui est titré une conjoncture
dégradée en voie d'amélioration
et pour ma part je ne perçois aucun
signe d'amélioration malheureusement
dans ce que l'on voit en france
aujourd'hui dans la situation économique
et sociale que nous vivons et je le
déplore fortement ils ne respectent pas
les avis du haut conseil que nous avons
créée il ya quelques mois et pour
lesquelles le gouvernement demande un
budget de 780 mille euros je pense que
on ferait bien de supprimer c'est au
conseil rapidement et de supprimer 780
mille euros ça nous ferait des économies
et on s'en porterait pas plus mal
puisque on ne respecte pas ces
ces observations et puis on annonce des
baisses de dépenses qui ne sont pas
puisqu'en fait céder non augmentation de
dépenses
et là il ya une vraie escroquerie
intellectuelle
donc pour toutes ces raisons je souhaite
que ce programme de stabilité qui n'est
pas un exercice de pure rhétorique
budgétaire d un engagement formel envers
nos partenaires européens mais surtout
envers l'avenir de nos concitoyens je
vous demande messieurs les ministres de
soumettre au vote du sénat votre
déclaration sur ce programme de
stabilité
je remercie merci mon cher collègue
actes et données de votre rappel au
règlement l'ordre du jour appelle une
déclaration du gouvernement suivie d'un
débat sur le projet de programme de
stabilité demande de la commission des
finances est mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement de l'article 50 1 de la
constitution
la parole est à monsieur pierre
moscovici ministre de l'économie et des
finances
ah bon
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
priorité absolue de la majorité c'est le
recul durable du chômage
toute notre politique unique vise à
mettre en oeuvre les conditions pour
atteindre cet objectif le rétablissement
de la compétitivité de notre tissu
productif la soutenabilité nos finances
publiques la mise en oeuvre de réformes
structurelles indispensables pour
libérer les forces notre économie et une
politique européenne plus favorables à
la croissance et le gouvernement comme
la majorité doivent répondre ensemble à
ces deux questions comment redresser nos
comptes sans étouffer la croissance et
quelles réformes menées pour susciter
activement la reprise de l'activité
c'est l'objet du premier programme
national de réformes et du premier
programme de stabilité que nous
présentons aujourd'hui jeudi apporter
des réponses précises et ambitieuses
avant d'entamer ce débat je tiens à vous
dire mes regrets de pouvoir y participer
jusqu'à son terme car je dois ensuite
partir pour la chine rouge accompagne le
président la république mais bernard
cazeneuve et là et prendra le relais ces
programmes
ils décrivent la stratégie économique du
gouvernement ainsi que le scénario
macroéconomique et la trajectoire des
finances publiques qui les sous tendent
ils disent aussi quelles réformes nous
mènerons pour atteindre les dix
prévisions de croissance mais ce ne sont
pas des lois de finances ça n'a pas être
votée exactement dans les mêmes formes
en même temps ce sont des textes c'est
vrai qu'ils ont une portée symbolique et
politique extrêmement forte
nous leur avons accordé le même soin ils
doivent être abordés par la
représentation nationale dans le même
esprit qui est un esprit de
responsabilité
on ne peut pas pas tellement là entamé
même processus d'une loi de finances
n'oublions pas que ces documents seront
ensuite transmises à la commission
européenne puis ensuite feront l'objet
commentaire de sa part avec de nouvelles
prévisions qu'il y aura des
recommandations dans la commission
européenne que ce sera adopté lors d'un
conseil ecofin a
mi juin et enfin par le conseil européen
des 27 et 28 juin voilà c'était le
programme de stabilité voilà ce qu'est
le programme national de réforme c'est
programme s'inscrit dans un contexte
difficile il faut rappeler en préambule
en premier lieu je le dis ici avec
douceur
nous avons un lourd héritage assumé je
me livre pas assez d'exercice pour le
plaisir de la rhétorique ou par volonté
de défausse ou de répétition
nous sommes en responsabilité nous le
gouvernement avec sa majorité
et c'est nous qui serons jugés sur nos
résultats mais en même temps les faits
sont têtus les conséquences de ces faits
sont lourds et c'est cela que nous avons
à faire l'héritage financier
terriblement pesant madame des esgaulx
terriblement pesant 600 milliards de
dettes supplémentaires un ratio de dette
rapportée à notre richesse nationale qui
a augmenté
écoutez bien de 20 points un déficit
structurel dégradée de 1 8 point en cinq
ans alors que tous les autres pays de la
zone euro en fait des efforts
d'ajustement structurel un déficit
nominal qui aurait été de 5 et demi pour
cent si le gouvernement avec la majorité
n'y avait pas mis bon ordre pour ramener
cela 88% en 2012
une des faiblesses structurelles aussi
une croissance nulle de 2007 à 2011
un chômage qui a crû de 1 million sous
le quinquennat précédent 750 mille
emplois perdus dans l'industrie en dix
ans une compétitivité qui s'est
lourdement affaibli en dix ans et que
révèle un déficit commercial encore
supérieur à 65 milliards d'euros en 2012
j'ai été membre d'un gouvernement entre
97 et 2002 et je me souviens qu'en 2002
la france était en excédent commercial
de 3 milliard et qu'à l'époque on
parlait de l'allemagne comme l'homme
malade de l'europe
regardez ce qui s'est passé je reviens
pas davantage là dessus si ce n'est que
pour souligner que face à une situation
aussi dégradée
nous devons nécessairement mener nos
efforts de redressement sur le long
terme
en second lieu nous sommes confrontés je
ne m'y attarde pas une crise sans
précédent dans la zone euro j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire ici et je le redis
nous avons apportées
réponse forte à la crise de la zone euro
la zone euro n'est plus menacée dans son
existence
la stabilité est revenue mais en même
temps la crise dans la zone euro demeure
c'est à dire une crise de croissance que
nous devons affronter
au moment même où la zone euro ce sont
les présidents des commissions pour être
avoir une deuxième année de récession
consécutive alors que le chômage atteint
19 touches 19 millions de personnes
résonneront à tel point que le président
de la commission européenne sur barroso
lui-même a été amené hier à dire qu'il
fallait revisiter les politiques
économiques européennes et dans ce
contexte je veux rappeler le sens de
notre action tout d'abord réformer au
bon rythme pour réussir le redressement
économique du pays est actuellement il
faut pas l'ignorer débat en france sur
le rythme du redressement des comptes
publics au regard de la nécessité de
soutenir la croissance
peut-on redresser l'économie ce sens
redresser les finances publiques
je me suis depuis un an souvent et
longuement exprimé devant vous pour dire
que le président la république a fait du
sérieux budgétaire un des axes de sa
politique onomique il faut pas opposer
remise en ordre des comptes et
croissance et personne ne peut dire ou
penser que l'endettement serait une
bonne chose pour l'économie une économie
qui s'endettent technique qui
s'affaiblit qui s'appauvrit qui perd de
sa souveraineté qui perdent liberté
surtout quand elle commença endettés à
s'endetter à des taux de plus en plus
cher nous avons la chance d'avoir des
taux historiquement bas il faut la
garder et la question n'est plus celle
là c'est comment concilier redressement
des finances publiques et croissance pas
en étant dogmatique pas en étant rigide
mais en passant un pilotage dit en
termes structurels en mettant l'accent
sur les dépenses publiques en engageant
nos finances publiques sur la voie d'un
assainissement en profondeur durable
mais aussi en laissant jouer les
stabilisateurs automatiques quand la
situation est comique l'exigent et à
l'évidence
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
crois qu'elles l'exigent
aujourd'hui c'est ainsi que nous
pourrons préserver les conditions de la
croissance
cette question du rythme de redressement
le gouvernement la porte avec force
depuis l'élection de françois hollande
dans tous les forums de coopération
économiques internationaux à l'échelle
européenne d'abord nous avons obtenu un
pacte de croissance qui désormais se
mettre en oeuvre dans nos relations
bilatérales notamment avec nos voisins
allemands et aussi dans les enceintes
multilatérales participé la semaine
dernière à washington aux assemblées
générales du fonds monétaire
international de la banque mondiale et
aux réunions du g20 et j'ai noté la une
convergence très forte autour d'un même
message davantage doit être fait pour la
croissance et pour l'emploi tout en
améliorant les efforts pour la
souveraineté et la soutenabilité
budgétaire et je vous le dis ici le
climat change c'est clair les priorités
l'économie mondiale elle se tourne
désormais davantage vers la croissance
sans oublier évidemment la gestion des
finances publiques
le sérieux ne peut pas ne doit pas être
abandonné les réponses de structures
sont indispensables mais l'austérité
n'est pas la solution et la voix chemin
que nous empruntons que nous voulons
proposer à l'europe
je pense que c'est la bonne voie et le
bon chemin j'en viens maintenant à nos
programmes est d'abord à nos prévisions
nos prévisions elles sont identiques
pour 2013 et 2014 à celle de la
commission européenne prudence réalisme
crédibilité 0 1% en 2013 et 2 en 2014
nous pensons qu ensuite les communes
françaises peut et va reprendre sur rail
de 2% par an entre 2015 et 2017
ce ne serait d'ailleurs qu'une partie du
rattrapage du retard de croissance qui
était accumulée dans les années passées
au regard de notre croissance
potentielle le haut conseil des finances
publiques nouvelle instance créée à
l'initiative du gouvernement pour
éclairer le débat parlementaire
symbole de transparence et de rénovation
en profondeur de gaulle en ses finances
publiques a rendu la semaine dernière
son avis sur ces prévisions je ne veux
pas le cacher ici et dans son avis il
estime que le scénario macroéconomique
gouvernement est entourée je cite d'un
certain nombre d'aléas qui dans leur
ensemble font peser un risque à la
baisse sur les prévisions
nous reconnaissons l'existence de
facteurs qui jouent à la baisse comme à
la hausse et au conseil les mentionne
aussi mais j'ai souhaité confirmer avec
bernard cazeneuve devant votre
commission des finances
mercredi dernier et je le redis ici les
prévisions du programme de stabilité
parce que tout simplement
j'ai la conviction que enfer mois serait
d'une part nous précipiter dans un
ajustement a justifié ce serait aussi
faire preuve d'un pessimisme ou une
défiance à l'égard de notre économie que
rien mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
rien ne justifie pas ce que les
prévisions que je vous présente deux
s'appuient sur deux convictions
la première c'est que l'europe va
progressivement redémarrer le plus gros
des efforts est passé pour la plupart
des pays
décision du pacte de croissance vont
produire leurs effets les pays sous
tension pour bénéficier de meilleures
conditions de financement grâce à la
mise en oeuvre résolue de l'union
bancaire non bancaires pour laquelle la
france vous le savez ce pas et quand je
dis union bancaire je pense à l'union
bancaire entière global pas uniquement
la supervision intégrés et ma deuxième
conviction c'est que les réformes que
nous menons en france portent leurs
fruits ces réformes
précisément elle constitue le substrat
du programme du même nom je voudrais me
arrêté un instant programme national de
réformes il envisage trois grands axes
d'abord on était à de compétitivité ce
gouvernement a pris plus de décisions
positives pour la compétitivité en onze
mois que tous ses prédécesseurs en dix
ans et 2013 sera consacré à la mise en
oeuvre et à l'approfondissement des
mesures prises d'abord la réorientation
du système fiscal pour encourager la
compétitivité et l'innovation
ce ça sera poursuivie encore à travers
les assises de l'entrepreneuriat qui se
réuniront lundi autour du président la
république mais c'est notamment le sens
des 20 milliards d'euros du crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité emploi qui
permettra de relever l'activité de 0 5
point qu'il crée trois cent mille
emplois d'ici 2017
nous avons également remis le secteur
financier au service de l'investissement
de l'économie réelle au service des pme
des outils nous l'avons fait avec la
création par exemple de la banque plus
d'investissements approuvés par votre
assemblée avec la loi bancaire approuvé
sans opposition par votre assemblée avec
le plan trésorerie ou encore le soutien
au financement de l'investissement des
collectivités locales et cette réforme
sera pas interrompue puisqu'il reste
encore des mesures à prendre par exemple
en matière de réforme de l'épargné
financière sur la base des travaux de
deux députés karine berger et 2000 le
faire c'est également pour soutenir
notre compétitivité nous mèneront en
2013 des réformes de structures majeures
qui sont indiqués ici concernant les
services l'énergie le logement le
ferroviaire avec un objectif faire
baisser les prix donc réduire les coûts
des entreprises et de 6,13 encore et
enfin le fait qu'avec benoît hamon nous
présenterons début mai un projet de loi
sur la consommation qui renforcera le
droit des consommateurs qui contribuera
à lutter contre les rentes injustifiées
et nous avons du secteur ferroviaire je
lui dis sera également présenté au
premier semestre de cette année deuxième
axe le gouvernement s'attache à préparer
l'avenir en encourageant la
structuration de l'économie autour de
filières industrielles en soutenant les
secteurs stratégiques par une politique
d'investissements ciblés
le gouvernement organisera au premier
semestre une consultation pour retenir
les initiatives industrielles
prioritaire pour le quinquennat soutenu
par un fonds multi sectorielle doigté
des 590 millions d'euros qui sera mis en
place au sein de la bpi en parallèle
nous mènerons une politique
d'investissement de long terme dans les
secteurs clés du logement de la
rénovation thermique du numérique sur ce
dernier point les mesures ont déjà été
prises
voilà ce que nous voulons faire enfin en
matière de lutte contre le chômage et la
précarité nous travaillerons tout au
long de l'année 2013 au plein
déploiement des mesures adoptées
beaucoup aussi par votre assemblée nous
amplifierons leurs effets par une grande
réforme d'information professionnelle
je citerai la création de 150 mille
emplois d'avenir d'ici fin 2014 qui va
réduire le chômage des jeunes je citerai
le plein déploiement des mesures
adoptées qui est aussi celui de la
réforme du marché du travail avec
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
11 janvier qui est identifié à
l'étranger je vous le dire je sais pas
si c'est toujours perçu comme ça en
france mais c'est pourtant la vérité
comme ainsi absolument majeur de la
vente et du gouvernement et des
partenaires sociaux
de permettre à la france de se réformer
en facilitant l'adaptation des
entreprises de choc structurelles tout
en accordant de nouveaux droits aux
salariés clé de voûte la la lutte contre
le chômage qui nous mobilise tous et je
le répète ce volet sera complété au
second semestre par la renégociation de
la convention d'assurance chômage et
surtout par une forme d'ampleur la
formation professionnelle ces réformes
et j'en viens donc de mon propos
permettent d'envisager un redressement
des comptes publics dont le rythme les
modalités seront tracés dans le
programme de stabilité qui a été
largement approuvée par l'assemblée
nationale hier la stratégie de remise en
ordre des comptes qu'il expose participe
du redressement économique auquel nous
travaillons parce que je le dis ici
redressement des comptes publics et
redressement de l'appareil productif
sont deux faces d'une même médaille le
sénat est fait pour construire monsieur
le président vous le savez bien c'est
important et le désendettement est un
facteur de compétitivité
j'aimerais que ce soit toujours votre
préoccupation et cette stratégie elle
est dictée par un impératif trouver le
bon équilibre le bon rythme pour la
remise en ordre de nos comptes quels
sont les trois temps distinctes nous
envisageons d'abord le premier temps
couvre 2013 nous ajusterons le rythme
d'assainissement des comptes pour ne pas
briser la croissance le second souffle
en 2014
pour finir on approfondiront notre
effort structurel pour nous donner les
moyens d'atteindre notre objectif de
déficit
ce sera une année de tournant de
basculement dans la répartition des
efforts entre recettes et dépenses vers
les économies de dépenses à partir de
2015 enfin nous commencerons à réduire
la part de l'endettement dans le pib ne
progressons pas le clip culturel grâce à
la montée en puissance de calcul comme
l'a dit le président françois hollande
ne peut le clip n'est pas une politique
d'austérité c'est une politique sérieuse
et juste pour 2013 donc nous éviterons
et nous le faisons consciemment
volontairement d'ajouter l'austérité la
récession et le déficit publics nominal
s'établira au chiffre prévu par la
commission européenne
3,7 pour cent ça veut dire que nous
refusons bernard cazenave et moi même
dans nos fonctions un nouveau plan
d'ajustement budgétaire
l'effort a déjà été considérables nous
ne présenterons pas de collectif
budgétaire
à cet effet pourquoi ça parce que
l'effort structurel de 1,9 point
c'est sans précédent en 2013 ne peut pas
être à
avait sans risque de récession et nous
ne voulons pas précipiter l'économie
française dans la récession nous voulons
laisser jouer les stabilisateurs
automatiques et faire en sorte en effet
que les moteurs de la croissance soient
soutenus nous refusons les conséquences
dramatiques pour l'emploi et pour les
entreprises qui résulterait d'un plan
d'austérité
et donc c'est une politique équilibrée
qui garde le cap du sérieux budgétaire
qui préserve le les capacités de
l'appareil économique accroître nous
tiendrons ce cap avec détermination je
veux vous l'assuré ici c'est en 2014
dans un second temps que nous nous
donnerons les moyens d'atteindre un
déficit à 2,9 pour cent grâce à un
effort structurel moins important de 1
point de pib qui nous permettra de
respecter nos engagements européens sont
brisés la croissance avec un effort
structurel qui reposera à 70% sur des
économies à 30% sur des recettes 2014
étant donc de nombreux écarts égard une
année charnière grâce notamment à la
montée en puissance de la modernisation
de l'action publique qui est une
condition sine qua none pour faire en
sorte que les économies ne se réalisent
pas comme ce fut le cas dans le passé
par un effet de toise aveugle qui s'est
appelée rgpp et qui n'est pas la bonne
façon de procéder
car si on veut moderniser il faut
toujours associer les usagers et aussi
faire en sorte que les agents je chante
engagé et je dis ici que nous
procéderons à l'évaluation de la
totalité des politiques publiques pour
permettre des économies intelligentes
permettant de préserver des priorités
sociales éducatives économiques dont les
français ont besoin
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
l'opposition même si ça vous gêne nous
irons dans ce sens là voilà mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les principaux
éléments de notre programme de stabilité
d'un programme national de réformes
notre ambition elle est connue s'inscrit
dans la durée nous voulons redresser le
pays rétablir ses comptes publics
rendre la france plus productive en
gardant toujours le souci de la justice
sociale de l'emploi en donnant priorité
toujours à l'investissement la jeunesse
et le gouvernement entend par les choix
qui vous
sont proposés associés crédibilité et
ambition adopter un rythme de
consolidation budgétaire qui ne pénalise
pas la croissance mettre en oeuvre des
réformes profondes qui préparent
l'avenir sans nous renier et ça prend du
temps ça prend du temps c'est vrai mais
le sillon se creuse mettre en oeuvre
donc ces réformes pour une économie plus
forte plus respectés pour donner les
moyens la france de peser davantage dans
la réorientation la construction
européenne dont je peux vous assurer
qu'elle est la volonté du président du
gouvernement
mais je le dis aussi d'un dernier mot ne
croyons pas que nous sommes plus forts
en europe si nous laissons faire ou si
nous laissons aller poil plus fort en
europe il faut d'abord être crédible
c'est cette ligne de crête que nous
suivons ses choix ce que nous vous
proposons refuser l'austérité dont les
français à juste titre ne veulent pas
mais ce sont des choix sérieux
ce sont des choix responsables ils sont
je le redis ambitieux ils sont réalistes
et j'attends du sénat à travers le débat
d'aujourd'hui plus que de la
compréhension le soutien à cette
politique qui est celle dont la france
tout simplement a besoin aujourd'hui je
vous remercie
merci la parole la parole à monsieur
bernard cazeau noise ministre chargé du
budget
bien mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais après pierre moscovici et
avec le souci de la complémentarité par
rapport au pos qui vient de tenir dire
quelques mots sur la trajectoire de
finances publiques dans laquelle nous
sommes engagés et que les crises
programme de stabilité en insistant plus
particulièrement sur quelques sujets
budgétaire car dans ce programme de
stabilité il ya des considérations qui
renvoie à l'évaluation que nous faisons
de la conjoncture économique d'un
certain nombre de données
macroéconomiques qui caractériseront
l'évolution de nos économies au cours
des prochaines années
mais il ya aussi une trajectoire
budgétaire qui nous engage et sur
laquelle il nous faudra année après
année à mesure que dans le cadre du
semestre européen nous présenterons nos
programmes de stabilité rendre compte
devant la représentation nationale des
conditions dans lesquelles nous athènes
nous atteignons nos objectifs en termes
d'indicateurs d'exeter
je voudrais profiter de cette séance
pour répondre très simplement
avant que le débat ne s'engage entre
nous à quelques questions simples
ces questions simples sont les suivantes
et je voudrais le faire en me fondant
non pas sur des impressions encore moins
sur le la volonté de polémique mais
simplement sur des chiffres première
question est ce que depuis l'alternance
qui s'est produite au mois de mai
dernier la situation des dépenses a
évolué ce que nous sommes ou non dans
une meilleure maîtrise des dépenses
publiques et dans quelle trajectoire
nous en serions nous pour les mois qui
viennent deuxième question à laquelle je
souhaite répondre avec vous y à t'il
comme cela parfois est avancé pas
systématiquement de façon nuancée une
volonté de procéder à des ajustements
budgétaires par la convocation
systématique de l'impôt comment a évolué
la pression fiscale
comment évoluera tél
les semaines les mois et les années qui
viennent et quelle est la politique
fiscale de ce gouvernement jusqu'à
l'horizon 2017
troisième question à laquelle je
souhaiterais pouvoir répondre avec vous
c'est qu'elle est contenue de ce qu'est
notre stratégie d'évolution des dépenses
et de notre politique fiscale
l'évolution prévisible de nos déficits
publics et enfin je voudrais répondre à
une dernière question et j'en aurai
terminé
quel est l'impact de cette politique
budgétaire de cette trajectoire de
finances publiques sur la croissance
et avant que d'évoquer ces quatre
questions reprenant quelques-uns des
éléments qui ont été évoqués de façon
très large et approfondie par le
ministre de l'économie et des finances à
l'instant je voudrais m'interroger avec
vous sur les hypothèses de croissance
qui ont été commentés par le haut
conseil des finances publiques est une
instance que nous avons créée au terme
de la ratification du traité de manière
à pouvoir disposer d'éléments objectifs
et je voudrais notamment regarder avec
vous l'appréciation que le haut conseil
des finances publiques portent sur les
hypothèses de croissance sur lesquelles
il faut non d'autres trajectoires ses
hypothèses de croissance sont les
suivantes 1 2% de croissance en 2014
puis 2% de croissance dans les années
qui suivent
comme l'a dit pierre moscovici l instant
cela suppose que nous continuons à être
volontariste pour aller chercher la
croissance là où elle se trouve et que
nous menions des politiques qui
permettent de faire en sorte que cette
croissance soit possible c'est ce qui
conduit le conseil des finances
publiques et un certain nombre
d'observateurs à considérer que nous
sommes optimistes ce que certains
appellent optimisme nous nous le
qualifions de volontarisme parce que
nous avons la volonté à la fois en
france et en europe de créer les
conditions de la croissance
et je pense que ce que nous proposons en
termes de stratégie de croissance doit
être apprécié à l'aune de ce qui a été
présenté par les gouvernements
précédents au titre des précédents
programmes de stabilité et je crois
qu'il ya une année très emblématique
de ce qu'a été la relation du
gouvernement précédent à la croissance
c'est l'année 2012 faut-il rappeler que
lorsque le projet de loi de finances
pour 2012 a été préparé par la
précédente majorité nous étions une
hypothèse de croissance de 1,75 pour
cent
tous ceux qui étaient là à l'époque se
souviennent que le projet de loi de
finances est bien le projet de loi de
finances se fonder sur une hypothèse
très optimiste dans 75 % lorsque la loi
de finances initiale a été débattue par
votre assemblée
nous étions à 1 % c'est-à-dire qu'en
quelques semaines pendant quelques mois
l'hypothèse avait été corrigé de 0 75%
puis une loi de finances rectificative
parce que c'était la modalité de
pilotage des affaires budgétaires il ya
de cela quelques mois on partait sur des
hypothèses très ambitieuses ont
multiplié les lois de finances
rectificatives de manière à corriger une
trajectoire qui n'avait pas été
totalement pertinente à l'origine
c'était surtout madame la sénatrice très
aléatoire parce que 1,75 puis un
quelques semaines après puis 0,5 et
quelques semaines après puis 0,7 dans le
programme de stabilité dans le raz
blanchard où j'ai appris à naviguer ça
s'appelle du navigue à la godille donc
c'était ça la méthode qui prévalait
beaucoup d'approximations dans les
hypothèses sur lesquelles se fondaient
la trajectoire et comme il y avait
beaucoup d'approximations dans les
hypothèses qui présidait à la définition
de la trajectoire mécaniquement il y
avait de beaux coups de correction en
cours de trajectoire c'est la raison
pour laquelle beaucoup de loi de
finances rectificative sont venus par le
passé corriger des hypothèses initiales
qui n'étaient pas toujours pertinente et
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
on nous demande aujourd'hui de
reproduire ce schéma c'est à dire de
nous engager dans des lois de finances
rectificative
ce que nous ne ferons pas pour l'année
il tresse ce que nous ne ferons pas pour
l'année 2013 parce que si nous faisions
cela cela signifierait que nous nous
apprêtons à corriger le niveau des
dépenses et le niveau des recettes
c'est-à-dire que nous apprêtons à
diminuer les dépenses et à augmenter les
impôts ce qui signifierait que nous
sommes dans une situation
particulièrement dégradée de l'économie
européenne et mondiale près ajouté de
l'austérité à l'austérité ce que nous ne
ferons pas je rappelle ces éléments
concernant les chiffres de croissance
tout simplement pour dire notamment aux
sénateurs de l'opposition et sénatrices
que je respecte dans les interrogations
qu'il formule que nous sommes beaucoup
plus prudents qu'ils ne l'ont été lors
de l'élaboration des lois de finances
précédente et que nous nous sommes
d'autant plus que l'hypothèse sur
laquelle nous fondons notre trajectoire
de finances publiques à la faveur de la
présentation de ce programme de
stabilité sont exactement les hypothèses
de la commission européenne puisque la
commission européenne pour l'année qui
s'ouvrira dans quelques mois et sur une
hypothèse de croissance pour l'heure de
1,2 pour cent
je vais ensuite en arriver aux quatre
questions que j'ai posées
la première question c'est comment
évolueront les dépenses dans le cadre de
ce programme de stabilité
au regard de ce qui a été l'évolution
des dépenses au cours des dix dernières
années
et peut-on à l'aune des résultats déjà
obtenus depuis près de douze mois
considéré que ce que nous préconisons en
termes d'évolution des dépenses
publiques et pertinents je voudrais m'en
tenir aux chiffres parce que même si
l'exercice budgétaire n'est pas une
science exacte il est une science
rigoureuse et on est dite d'autant plus
facilement les polémiques et les mauvais
débat que l'on à dos le raisonnement que
l'on tient à des chiffres incontestables
et les chiffres dont je vais parler
leçon puisqu'il n'appartiennent pas à
des spéculations pour l'avenir mais
à des choses constaté pour le passé
d'abord les pourcentages d'évolution des
dépenses publiques au cours des dix
dernières années entre 2002 et 2007
l'évolution des dépenses publiques a été
de 2 3% en moyenne pendant la période
l'évolution des dépenses publiques
entre 2007 et 2012 a été de 1,7 pour
cent en moyenne pendant la période en
2012 pour des raisons sur lesquelles je
vais revenir dans un instant nous avons
une évolution des dépenses publiques qui
est de 0 7% là où nous étions engagés
sur un objectif de zéro sac
le décalage de 0,2 résulte simplement
d'une dépense plus dynamiques des
collectivités locales mais personne ne
peut nier qu'ils connaissaient chiffres
dans cet hémicycle que nous sommes dans
un rapport de 1 à 4 en termes de
dynamique d'évolution des dépenses
publiques
entre 2002 2012 et la trajectoire la
tendance sur laquelle nous sommes depuis
le début de l'année je vais également
signalé qu'en 2012 nous avons eu une
diminution des dépenses de l'état libyen
des dépenses de l'état pour la première
fois quasiment depuis le début de la
vème république de 300 millions d'euros
là où les dépenses de l'état avait
augmenté en moyenne au cours des années
précédentes 2 6 milliards par an 5 à 6
milliards par an notre objectif pour
2014 est une diminution des dépenses de
l'état de l'ordre de 1,5 milliard
d'euros
c'est la raison pour laquelle je trouve
qu'il ya peu de modération dans la
critique qui nous est adressé de
l'incapacité dans laquelle nous serions
de maîtriser les dépenses publiques
alors que lorsqu'on regarde les taux
d'évolution des dépenses publiques et
l'évolution nominale des dépenses de
l'état nous constatons encore une fois
que le rythme d'évolution des dépenses
publiques s'est réduit dans une
proportion de 1 à 4 est que pour la
première fois
nous voyons les dépenses de l'état
diminué là où elles augmenté dans les
proportions que je viens d'indiquer dans
les années précédentes on pourrait
considérer que les dépenses de l'état et
les dépenses publiques évoluent de façon
contrastée que ce que je dis sur les
dépenses de l'état n'est pas
nécessairement vrai pour ce qui concerne
d'autres dépenses publiques je veux
parler des dépenses de protection
sociale le quand même rappeler là aussi
des chiffres précis qu'ils peuvent être
contestées par personne qui est
intellectuellement honnête sur ces
questions les dépenses de l'ondam qui ne
sont pas des dépenses qui concerne une
enveloppe réduite dans les dépenses
publiques globales
les dépenses de l'ondam ont augmenté
d'un peu plus de 2% dans le courant de
l'année précédente faut-il rappeler
qu'au cours du dernier quinquennat
les dépenses de l'ondam en moyenne
annuelle ont évolué depuis le 4 % nous
sommes dans un rapport de 1 à 2 pour ce
qui concerne les dépenses d'assurance
maladie
entre ce qui s'est passé dans le
précédent quinquennat essais qui se
passe depuis le début du quinquennat qui
vient de débuter et lorsque l'on prend
la trajectoire global prévu par le
précédent gouvernement en 2012
concernant les dépenses d'assurance
maladie on constate que par un effort de
maîtrise de ses dépenses
nous avons par rapport à la projection
de la précédente majorité un milliard de
moins de dépenses et en termes de
dépenses d'assurance maladie en 2012 ce
qui a permis une diminution de l'ordre
de 4 milliards entre 2011 et 2012 des
dépenses du déficit du régime général
là où entre 2006 et 2011
il avait évolué de façon spectaculaire
de 6 milliards
donc voilà quels sont les chiffres
concernant la dépense ces chiffres sont
incontestables et je trouve qu'ils
témoignent du mauvais procès qui nous
est fait lorsque nous sommes soumis à la
critique de ceux qui ont contribué à
l'aggravation des dettes dérapage de la
dépense publique au creusement des
déficits et qui ignore les résultats que
je viens d'indiquer comme pour
s'exonérer de leurs responsabilités pour
le passé ne pas reconnaître ce que sont
les trajectoires dans lesquelles nous
sommes engagés depuis que nous sommes en
situation de responsabilité et pour
l'avenir et je rejoindrai volontiers les
propos tenus par le sénateur jean
arthuis à l'occasion de la réunion de la
commission des finances il ya de cela
quelques jours dans cette assemblée
lorsque jean arthuis disais que sur les
questions budgétaires il peut y avoir
des orientations politiques différentes
mais qu'il ya une réalité à laquelle
l'on n'échappe pas c'est la réalité des
chiffres établis qui retrace la réalité
du passé et dans le passé dont nous
parlons il ya une partie du passé qui
renvoie une situation ne l'étions pas en
situation de responsabilité et il y a un
passé dont nous sommes comptables qui
est celui dont je rends compte à
l'instant pour ce qui relève de l'action
que nous avons conduite depuis 12 mois
voilà pour les dépenses la deuxième
question dont je voulais parler c'est
celle de la pression fiscale et 2
la stratégie fiscale qui est celle de ce
gouvernement pour les années qui
viennent
d'abord je veux rappeler que le semestre
européen a cet avantage qu'il permet à
nos deux assemblées d'être parfaitement
informée a franchi quant aux intentions
des gouvernements devant l'union
européenne le semestre européen a ce
mérite qui nous invite
année après année à la faveur de
l'examen de ces pactes de stabilité a
indiqué quelles sont nos trajectoires
quelles sont nos indicateurs quelles
sont nos statistiques et par conséquent
permet aux sénateurs et aux députés
année après année de constater le
décalage qui existe entre les objectifs
qu'on s'est assignée à soi même
et les résultats qu'on a obtenus et par
conséquent lorsque l'on regarde le
programme de stabilité présenté par la
précédente majorité et qui prévoyait des
augmentations d'impôts on constate que
la trajectoire fiscale du précédent
gouvernement est à peu près la même en
termes de pourcentage et d'évolution à
quelques jeux ya près de ce que nous
nous proposons de faire en termes
d'évolution pourquoi tout simplement
parce que les déficits sont à ce point
important est la dette à ce point
significative qu'il est impossible de
procéder à l'ajustement de nos finances
publiques par la seule mobilisation de
la diminution des dépenses publiques
car si nous le faisions nous remettrions
en cause des services publics qui
constitue dans la crise de patrimoine de
ceux qui n'ont rien et le ministre du
budget est aussi le ministre du
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas et
par conséquent nous devons veiller
lorsque nous procédons à des économies à
ne pas remettre en cause les services
publics et la protection sociale parce
que si nous le faisions cela aurait des
conséquences récessive évident qu'il
faut bien convoqué l'impôt de façon
raisonnable
lorsqu'on veut ajusté et nous nous avons
cherché à le faire dans la justice
alors je voudrais indiquer quelle est
notre trajectoire de fiscale pour les
années qui viennent et notamment pour
l'année 2014 pour l'année 2014 nous
aurons un effort à faire de 20 milliards
comme l'indiqué le président de la
république qui vous rendrait compte
lorsque je présenterai la loi de
finances pour 2014 devant votre
assemblée que cet engagement sera
respectée cet effort sera fait pour les
deux tiers à travers des économies et
pour un tiers à travers une augmentation
de la pression fiscale qui représentera
un effort de 0 3% en 2014 qui
s'atténuera dans les années qui suivent
au point d'avoir en 2016 2017 à taux de
pression fiscale comparable à celui
que nous avions en 2013 c'est à dire que
l'effort fiscal demandé en 2014 sera
qu'on passait dans les années qui
suivent ces 6 milliards d'euros
d'efforts fiscale comment les documenter
d'où vient-il constitue-t-il ce que
certains d'entre vous appelle un
matraquage fiscal la réponse est non la
réponse est non pourquoi
parce que dans ces 6 milliards d'euros
il ya d'abord un milliard d'euros
d'augmentation de cotisations sociales
déjà acté dans le cadre de l'accord
passé entre les partenaires sociaux au
titre du régime des retraites
complémentaires agirc arrco donc cela
est déjà actée et engrangé il y a des
recettes qui était prévu dans le budget
2013 mais qui n'ont pas été réalisés
pour des raisons qui tiennent notamment
au fait que des recettes n'ont pas donné
le rendement attendu je pense notamment
à la taxe sur les transactions
financières qui tient aussi au fait que
le conseil constitutionnel a annulé un
certain nombre de dispositions qui
devait produire recettes fiscales je
pense notamment à la taxe sur les 75 %
le budget de 2014 sera l'occasion à
hauteur de 1 milliard de procéder à la
récupération de ce produit fiscal qui
était envisagée en 2013 et qui pour les
raisons que je viens d'indiquer n'a pas
donné le rendement attendu ou n'a pas
été perçue ensuite nous avons à peu près
4 milliards d'euros que nous attendons
de la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et
de la poursuite du travail que nous
avons engagées sur les niches fiscales
et les niches sociales
je veux rappeler que la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale a permis en 2012
d'augmenter de 2 milliards le niveau de
recettes résultant de cette action de
l'administration fiscale contre les
fraudeurs nous avons l'intention de
continuer et d'intensifier ce travail
parce que ce qu'ils doivent acquitter
l'impôt en france en raison des règles
fiscales qui régissent le fonctionnement
de nos finances publiques doivent
acquitter cet impôt est tout ce que nous
prélevons sur ceux qui essaient d'y
échapper est bon pour nos recettes est
bon pour nos équilibres
du budgétaire et de surcroît ses
citoyens est juste et nous avons
également l'intention de poursuivre par
un nettoyage des niches fiscales et
sociales voilà d'où viennent les 6
milliards et je veux dire devant le
sénat et nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre
à l'occasion des prochains mois et des
prochaines années que nous ajusterons
par les économies les prochains budgets
et nous nous solliciterons l'impôt qu'à
la marge lorsque cela sera vraiment
indispensable les économies seront
désormais le moyen privilégié de l'
équilibre de nos budgets pour favoriser
la croissance et faire en sorte que
l'économie puisse redémarrer et le
président de la république aura dans
quelques jours sur ces sujets à
s'exprimer pour ce qui concerne
notamment la fiscalité des entreprises
je voudrais par ailleurs dire quelques
mots c'est le troisième sujet sur les
déficits parce que non seulement nous
avons une meilleure maîtrise des
dépenses nous avons une politique
fiscale raisonnable mais elle a un
impact sur les déficits
faut-il rappeler ces chiffres sont
incontestables aussi incontestables le
déficit structurel de la france est
passée de 30 à 100 milliards de 30 à 100
milliards
à l'occasion du précédent quinquennat de
30 à 100 milliards
en pourcentage en pourcentage il a
augmenté de près de 2%
lorsque l'on regarde l'évolution de la
dette
elle a pris 25 points de pib à
l'occasion du dernier quinquennat
quelle est l'évolution du déficit
structurel depuis 2012
en 2012 nous avons trouvé une situation
parfaitement photographié par un audit
de la cour des comptes que nous avons
sollicités qui montraient qu'il y avait
un risque de dérapage des dépenses à
hauteur de 2 milliards et une
surestimation manifeste des recettes
fiscales à hauteur de 8
nous avons donc pris des dispositions de
caractère fiscal en sollicitant 7
milliards de prélèvements
supplémentaires ne pouvions pas faire
autrement puisque nous arrivions
et nous avons part à une recherche
d'économies assurent elles
maîtriser les dépenses de l'état le
résultat de cela est que nous avons
réussi à éviter le dérapage du déficit
nominal
il aurait été de 5,5 si nous n'avions
pas pris ces mesures il n'a été que de
4,8 et s'il ya une différence de 0,3
entre la cip qui était la nôtre c'est à
dire 4 5 et les 4-8 constater c'est pour
des raisons qui tiennent à des
événements exceptionnels qui s'appelle
la nécessaire recapitalisation de dexia
qui s'appelle la nécessité d'absorber
800 millions d'euros au titre du budget
européen parce qu'on avait décidé de
sous-évaluer les crédits de paiement
nécessaire au financement des politiques
de l'union et qu'il a fallu à la demande
de la commission européenne
rattraper ce retard cela résulte aussi
du fait que le déficit 2011 a été de 5
3%
là où on s'attendait à ce qu'il ne soit
que de 5,2 donc c'est 0 1% en 2011 ont
un impact sur le déficit 2012 et il y a
il est vrai une part de responsabilité
qui nous incombe
puisque nous avions fondé la loi de
finances rectificative sur une hypothèse
de 0,3 et que nous avons en réalité une
croissance moindre qui explique aussi le
décalage qui existe entre le déficit sur
lequel nous nous étions engagés et de
déficits réels constatés mais en terme
de déficit 2012 aura été la première
année de diminution significative du
déficit structurel 1,2 pour cent nous
avons un objectif de 1,8 pour cent en
2013 est un objectif de 1 % en 2014 ces
chiffres sont des cif incontestable je
comprends qu'ils gênent puisqu'ils vont
à l'encontre d'une opération d'enfumage
constante à laquelle nous devons faire
face mais ils sont simplement la réalité
des chiffres constatée et en matière
budgétaire
on ne peut pas échapper à la réalité des
chiffres
voilà pour ce qui concerne les dépenses
voilà pour ce qui concerne la fiscalité
voilà pour ce qui concerne les déficits
alors maintenant je conclurai par la
croissance
est ce que cette politique de rigueur
car il faut la qualifier dans laquelle
nous sommes engagés est une politique
qui nous éloigne de l'investissement et
de l'ambition de croissance devrait
simplement rappelé que ce gouvernement
s'est engagé en mobilisant les moyens de
l'union et ses moyens propres dans une
stratégie d'investissement extrêmement
ambitieuse je vais là aussi prendre des
contres des exemples concrets pour
conclure à 20 milliards d'euros
d'équipement numérique des territoires
sur dix ans deux volontés d'accompagner
la construction de cinq cent mille
logements sociaux à travers des efforts
significatifs et de diminution de la tva
sur la construction de logements sociaux
neufs volonté de faire en sorte que tout
cela permette d'accompagner le bâtiment
dans sa relance parce que on sait à quel
point
l'activité du bâtiment a un impact sur
la croissance
nous pourrions également évoqué les 120
milliards d'euros du pacte de croissance
négocier au mois de juin qui sera
d'ailleurs à l'ordre du jour du conseil
européen de mai et qui représente pour
la france un volume global
d'investissements de 10 milliards
vous dites taratata madame des ego mais
moi je vais vous je vais vous proposer
c'est jean arthuis salle lur ça lui
ressemble moi mais je propose
si vous en êtes d'accord qu'à l'occasion
de la prochaine réunion de la commission
des finances de votre assemblée je
vienne avec la déclinaison par
territoire de ce plan de croissance ce
qui permettra d'en établir la
traçabilité pour chacun et d'arrêter ce
mauvais débat sur l'existence d'un plan
de croissance que nous sommes les seuls
à ignorer alors que l'ensemble des
acteurs de la commission européenne y
travaillent et le mettre à l'ordre du
jour du conseil européen du mois de mai
prochain et qu'il est considéré par la
plupart des pays de l'union européenne
comme une chance donc ce que nous
faisons en terme de rigueur ne se fait
pas au détriment de l'investissement qui
est un élément déterminant de la
croissance dont nous avons besoin parce
que je conclue en disant que la
politique que nous menons et que
matérialise ce pacte de stabilité repose
sur un équilibre subtil entre la
nécessité du redressement des comptes
d'une part et d'autre part l'existence
de la croissance
parce que sans l'établissement des
comptes il n'y aura pas de croissance et
sans croissance nous n'avons aucune
chance de rétablir dans la durée une
situation de finances publiques depuis
très longtemps dégradé merci la parole à
monsieur françois marc rapporteur
général du budget
monsieur président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues chacun ici mesure
l'importance du programme de stabilité
du programme national de réforme puisque
ils définissent une stratégie appelée à
être ensuite évalués par nos partenaires
européens
c'est donc un moment clé du semestre
européen qui justifie l'existence de ce
débat au parlement
et je dirais que l'enjeu ne se situe pas
seulement au niveau national en effet
l'interdépendance des économies et des
politiques budgétaires invite à porter
un regard global sur notre capacité à
définir les chemins de sortie de crise
les questions qui sont posées à la
france se pose en effet partout dans la
zone euro elle appelle à consolider la
dynamique de résolution de la crise à
l'échelle arabe européenne et à mieux
coordonner les politiques publiques
de ce point de vue on doit
monsieur le ministre se féliciter de
voir aujourd'hui l'europe se saisir de
sujets majeurs qui avaient été les
laisser en jachère depuis des années
comme la tension nouvelle portée à la
croissance économique la création de
lignon bancaire la taxe sur les
transactions financières ou encore
l'annoncé récente de la mise sur pied
d'une plateforme de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
on peut le dire mes chers collègues la
volonté régulatrice des autorités
européennes s'affirme enfin de façon
plus déterminée depuis quelques mois
force est de constater que si l'europe
s'anime davantage c'est parce que la
parole de la france plaident en ce sens
et sans doute parce qu'elle est entendue
mais c'est aussi parce que les autorités
européennes comme beaucoup de
prescripteurs mondiaux qu'il soit au fmi
qu'il soit à l' ocde la banque mondiale
prennent conscience du
une lourde erreur d'analysé économique
qui depuis plusieurs années a conduites
à préconiser une médication osterrieth
air pouvant conduire le malade européen
à mourir guéri force est de constater en
effet que les théories néolibérales
inspiré par ricardo ont conduit à
sous-estimer les faits déflagratoire des
mesures brutales de réduction des
déficits publics et sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui sous le feu des critiques la
théorie keynésienne que certains avaient
bien imprudemment jeter dans les
poubelles de l'histoire
et depuis peu l'objet d'une subite
réhabilitation il suffit pour s'en
convaincre d'écouter les récentes
déclarations de jacques guillou de
christine lagarde d'olli rehn ou de
manuel barroso et le ministre de
l'économie et des finances le disais
tout à l'heure
ici en parlant d'un changement
climatique dans les grandes instances
européennes aujourd'hui relativement à
cette volonté de réorientation vers la
croissance qui est exprimé par tous nul
ne peut ignorer aujourd'hui en france ce
contexte général européen et mondial
particulièrement exigeant
le programme de stabilité le programme
national de réformes doivent dans ces
conditions concilier deux exigences
d'abord celle du redressement de nos
finances publiques et de la réduction de
notre endettement
c'est un impératif moral parce qu'il
convient de limiter et demain de réduire
le poids qui pèse sur les jeunes
générations de nombreux défis nous
attendent notamment le vieillissement de
la population y faire face exigera de
retrouver davantage de marge de
manoeuvre budgétaire et donc de réduire
dès aujourd'hui notre dette publique
il faut d'ailleurs rappeler à l'occasion
que celle ci s'est accrue de près de 600
milliards d'euros au cours de la
précédente législature augmentation
d'ailleurs que la crise est très loin de
totalement expliquée et donc aujourd'hui
indispensable d'inverser cette tendance
mais il ya une loque l'exil
ans celle d'éviter que cet ajustement
par sa brutalité conduisent à une
récession qui nous empêcheraient
d'inverser une autre courbe celle du
chômage elles ne seraient pas acceptées
par le concitoyen et nuirait à la
conduite des réformes indispensables
pour notre pays il m est cher collègue
indispensable de préserver la croissance
tous nos partenaires le fmi est
désormais les institutions européennes
en conviennent
un ajustement trop brutal n'est pas
souhaitable et il serait absurde de
vouloir suivre une trajectoire
prédéfinis à n'importe quel prix quelle
que soit la conjoncture
le projet de programme de stabilité du
gouvernement manifeste à cet égard un
utile discernement il entend repoussé à
l'atteinte de l'objectif d'un déficit
public inférieur à 3% de pib
ce faisant le gouvernement suit à cap
parfaitement clair il avance avec
détermination sur la voie du
redressement des finances publiques en
se préoccupant de la justice sociale et
en préparant les perspectives de
croissance le gouvernement poursuit cela
consolidation engagé de nos finances
publiques car reporter la tan des trois
pour cent ne veut certainement pas dire
renoncer aux efforts la trajectoire
d'ajustement structurel qui nous est
proposée est celle ci est d'ailleurs
conforme aux engagements européens de la
france
elle est ambitieuse elle prévoit en
effet des efforts accentuée par rapport
à la loi de programmation des finances
publiques votées à la fin de l'année
dernière les efforts programmés sont
très conséquents
faut-il le rappeler sur le ministre a
indiqué à 1 point de pib soit 20
milliards d'euros en 2014 d'efforts 110
milliards d'effort au total sur la
période 2012 2017
cet effort a porté principalement en
2012 et 2013 sur les recettes et pour
les ménages sur les plus aisés
d'entre eux en fonction de leur capacité
cette stratégie est ce justifié
économiquement car à court terme faire
porter l'effort sur les recettes à à
moindres effets dépressifs que réduire
la dépense publique en outre faire
porter l'effort sur les ménages les plus
aisés permet de limiter l'impact négatif
sur la demande un effort important
également été demandées aux entreprises
mais celui ci est déjà en partie
compensée par le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité l'emploi qui à terme
allégera la charge des entreprises
d'environ 20 milliards d'euros le
gouvernement
les deux ministres viennent de nous le
précisait entend désormais faire porter
l'essentiel de l'ajustement sur la
dépense publique dès 2014
mes chers collègues elles supporteront
70 % de l'effort contre 30% pour les
recettes sur la période 2013 2017
couvertes par le programme de stabilité
l'effort portera pour près des deux
tiers sur les dépenses cet effort
considérable pour être durable et
intelligente suppose une préparation
une concertation est une méthode c'est
le sens des démarches engagées par le
gouvernement en particulier dans le cas
de la modernisation de l'action publique
il ne s'agit pas d'être dans une logique
aveugle de réduction des dépenses mais
au contraire de préserver l'accès aux
services publics de moderniser notre
modèle social pour en garantir les
fondements et de favoriser bien sûr les
politiques au service de la cohésion
sociale et de la croissance de demain
la situation des finances publiques
héritées du passé est un lourd fardeau
mais son redressement est une nécessité
il est bien engagé
si nous ne le faisons pas aujourd'hui
demain la charge de notre dette
exigerait des ajustements encore plus
douloureux ce redressement
n'empêche pas le gouvernement de mener
sa politique une politique de gauche
le budget pluriannuel adopté l'an
dernier marc des priorités fortes en
faveur de l'enseignement de la cohésion
sociale de la sécurité et de la justice
des initiatives fortes ont été engagés
en faveur de la justice sociale comme le
plan quinquennal de lutte contre la
pauvreté ou les dispositions prises en
faveur du logement
je voudrais enfin insisté sur la
crédibilité de la trajectoire présenté
par le gouvernement
cette crédibilité est un capital
précieux mais aussi fragile notamment
parce que notre pays n'a pas toujours
respecté ses engagements par le passé le
gouvernement a déjà montré sa
détermination à maîtriser les dépenses
pour la première fois en 2012 les
dépenses de l'état ont été inférieures à
celles de 2011
il a également engagé des réformes
structurelles d'ampleur qui permettront
de rétablir durablement la compétitivité
de notre économie
la poursuite et la réorientation du
programme d'investissements d'avenir
la création de la banque publique
d'investissement le pacte national pour
la croissance la compétitivité et
l'emploi ou encore le choc de
simplification notamment en direction
des petites et moyennes entreprises
cette crédibilité mes chers collègues
elle est nécessaire pour la mobilisation
de notre pays et de tous ses acteurs car
la fixation d'un cap sur l'ensemble de
la lisent la thur doivent favoriser le
retour de la confiance
cette crédibilité est aussi déterminante
vis-à-vis de notre partenaire européen
eu égard aux nouvelles règles dont nous
avons décidé collectivement il faut les
appliquer avec discernement mais nous ne
pouvons pas écarter par facilité le
règlement de copropriété de l'euro c'est
l'expression que jean arthuis utilisé
ici même le règlement de copropriété de
l'euro sans mettre en péril le
venir de l'ensemble de la zone euro
cette crédibilité
elle est enfin importante vis-à-vis des
investisseurs car elle permet de
contenir le poids de la dette
je me plaisent à souligner ici mais je
reconnais que les taux très bas auquel
nous émettons nos titres de dette et la
réduction de l'écart avec l'allemagne
s'explique par de multiples facteurs
mais il monte il montre que
contrairement à ce que certains
prévoyaient la politique conduite par ce
gouvernement ne suscite pas la défiance
des investisseurs j'allais dire bien au
contraire
le projet de programme de stabilité
repose sur des hypothèses de croissance
que le haut conseil des finances
publiques a certes certains l'ont déjà
mentionné en commission jugée optimiste
mais pas irréaliste
en la matière les variables sont
nombreuses les leur évolution est
incertaine mais les prévisions du
gouvernement ne sont pas hors de portée
leurs fondements sont crédibles qu'il
s'agisse de l'augmentation de la demande
internationale adressée à la france ou
celle de la demande intérieure portés
par une baisse modérée du taux d'épargné
des ménages
si la croissance n'était pas au rendez
vous à un niveau permettant un retour
sous les 3% en 2014 la question de la
mise en oeuvre d' ajustement
supplémentaire serait posée c'est une
décision qu'il conviendra de prendre
avec nos partenaires européens mais il
faut avant tout inscrire notre
trajectoire de redressement dans la
durée ce que fait ce programme de
stabilité
j'ai déjà souligné qu'au niveau de
l'union européenne les progrès accomplis
depuis un an sont considérables à
travers notamment l'action de la banque
centrale européenne les avancées
concernant l'union bancaire et le pacte
pour la croissance portée par le priant
de la république
il assure la crédibilité de la zone euro
qui repose sur sa capacité à mettre en
oeuvre une discipline collective mais
aussi sur sa capacité à aller vers plus
d'intégration et de solidarité
cette crédibilité
est acquise à travers les efforts
collectivement consenti doit permettre
aujourd'hui de mieux prendre en compte
la question de la croissance
c'est le sens de l'action du président
de la république et du gouvernement
depuis bientôt un an
une prise de conscience semble émerger
au niveau européen
si j'en juge par quelques signaux
envoyés ces derniers jours et chacun
sera attentif à toutes ces déclarations
dont j'ai déjà fait état au niveau des
autorités européennes en la matière
encore récemment c'était hier celle de
manuel barroso qui nous indique à quel
point à quel point il voue aujourd'hui
s'investir dans une réorientation vers
une stratégie axée sur la croissance
j'en termine mes chers collègues en
souhaitant tout simplement ici que nous
puissions obtenir auprès de nos
partenaires européens
le report souhaité par le gouvernement
français de l'atteinte du seuil des 3% à
2014 mais aussi leur confiance dans
notre détermination à mettre en oeuvre
les efforts pour rétablir nos finances
et notre compétitivité
au delà de la situation de la france et
je sais que vous y êtes particulièrement
sensible monsieur le ministre du budget
je souhaite que l'union européenne
puisse en maintenant une discipline
collective relance et des politiques
assurant un retour rapide de la
croissance et à travers elle une
dynamique porteuse d'avenir pour le
projet européen remercie
merci pour tous pour suivre dans nos
débats la parole est maintenant aux
orateurs des groupes
la parole est à monsieur jean arthuis
pour le groupe e -u des é -u c
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
programme de stabilité et le programme
national de réforme sont des actes
majeurs que le gouvernement met en débat
furtivement devant le parlement avant de
les transmettre à la commission
européenne at majeur puisqu'il engage la
trajectoire budgétaire jusqu'en 2017
acte majeur puisqu'il encadre les
prochaines lois de finances et les
prochaines lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale acte majeur parce
qu'ils décrivent les pistes de réformes
qui permettent d'atteindre de tenir les
objectifs
dès lors comment pouvons nous admettre
chers collègues que le sénat ne puisse
sanctionner ce débat par un vote
il y à quelques instants pierre
moscovici a conclu son propos en
exprimant le souhait que le sénat
soutiennent le gouvernement mais mes
chers collègues comment manifestons son
soutien sinon par l'expression d'un vote
certes l'année dernière il n'y avait pas
eu de vote il n'y avait pas eu de débat
non plus pour raison d'élections
présidentielles mais je vous rappelle
qu'en avril 2011
le précédent gouvernement avait eu
l'élégance avait eu le courage de
soumettre sans programme à ce vote ce
qui l'avait conduit à revoir son
hypothèse de croissance qui l'avait
ramené de 2% à 1 75% prévisions qui
s'étaient révélés justes
à l'époque nous entrions ainsi dans ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler désormais le
semestre européen
jusque-là convenons-en le programme de
stabilité constituait un exercice formel
un exercice dérisoire
destiné à rassurer à bon compte nos
partenaires européens
à défaut de nous rassurer nous mêmes
fondée sur l'illusionnisme budgétaire le
volontarisme des hypothèses de
croissance et dans la plupart des cas la
sous-évaluation des dépenses il a fallu
le séisme suscitées par la crise des
dettes souveraines pour changer la donne
et pour changer la procédure désormais
la solidarité des états membres de la
zone euro nous ordonne de sortir du déni
de réalité pour des impératifs d'ordre
européens certes mais d'abord et avant
tout dans l'intérêt de la france dont
l'intérêt du redressement de notre
économie et de l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage
c'est dire si l'interdiction de vote
constitue pour le sénat une véritable
humiliation
comment monsieur le président comment la
majorité du sénat ont elles pu accepter
cette résignation au delà de la
protestation
au delà de la protestation qu exprime au
nom du groupe
udi union centriste je veux expliciter
les deux critiques majeures capelle le
dispositif mis en forme par le
gouvernement soulignant ainsi le
contraste qui les différencie de nos
propres options en premier lieu
s'agissant des prévisions de croissance
nous avions cru comprendre qu'en créant
le haut conseil des finances publiques
le gouvernement avait enfin décidé et
c'était admirable avait enfin décidé de
rompre avec la vieille est coupable
pratique des prévisions volontaristes
malheureusement il n'en est rien le haut
conseil tout juste installé affiche
d'emblée
une louable indépendance faisons taire
les suspicions qu'avait suscité le
projet de sa création
en effet le haut conseil a osé il a osé
au terme de ces analyses déclaré que la
france cette année est en récession
face à ce langage de vérité amplement
confirmé par les signes que nous
vérifions tous les jours dans nos
départements et nos circonscriptions
la montée du chômage les procédures
d'alert les dépôts de bilan de très
nombreuses entreprises
en dépit de cela le gouvernement
persiste dans sa vision irréaliste
il est vrai que la trajectoire
budgétaire tant plus facilement vers la
résorption des déficits dès lors que les
hypothèses de croissance sont dopées
artificiellement
vous avez donc choisi monsieur le
ministre de perpétuer des méthodes
douteuses
historiquement daté pour mieux sauver
les apparences
qui peut croire à une croissance de 2%
dès 2015 pour que cela se vérifie il
faudrait mettre un oeuvre des réformes
structurelles qui contreviennent et qui
à la vérité contredisent vos dogmes
votre stratégie de redressement n'est
pas à la hauteur de la situation
dramatique de notre pays et ses songes
vous prie de nous renvoyer la balle sur
ce qui aurait pu et dû être accompli
hier par les équipes au pouvoir
qu'il s'agisse de la rigueur budgétaire
de la durée du temps de travail ou des
normes
c'est vrai que hier on a laissé filer le
déficit public
c'est vrai qu'hier on a oublié d'abroger
les 35 heures et qu'on s'en est remis
trop facilement à des usines à gaz
donc cessons de nous renvoyer ainsi la
balle ce qui compte c'est se sortir de
cette crise et de redonner l'espoir et
la confiance à nos concitoyens ce que
vous nous proposez aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre ne peut suffire à enrayer le
processus de déclin efforçons nous donc
de nous rassembler sur l'essentiel et
j'en viens à ma seconde critique vos
réformes sont symboliques et ne peuvent
produire les effets attendus
la banque publique d'investissement
n'est que le recyclage d'oseo de cdc
entreprises et du fonds stratégique
d'investissement avec en prime une
gouvernance que je qualifierais
d'abracadabrantesques ainsi qu'en
témoigne son dispositif de communication
et de porte parolat
et à mon avis on n'a pas tout vu
quant au crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi
il perpétue la complexité sa circulaire
d'application tient à temps d'une
quarantaine de pages
c'est sans doute l'illustration du choc
de simplification prescrit par le
président hollande se cice opère à la
marge
un allègement des charges sociales très
en deçà des préconisations de louis
gallois
elle même en deçà de ce qu'il
conviendrait de faire c'est-à-dire de
basculer au moins 50 milliards de
cotisations sociales
un tel choc de compétitivité ne peut
être financée que par une taxe sur les
produits y compris donc les produits que
nous importons et que nous consommons
est pour l'essentiel cette taxe serait
un supplément de tva
ce ne serait plus un impôt de production
nous commençons enfin à reconnaître ici
et là que les impôts sur la production
poussent à la délocalisation des
activités et par conséquent à la montée
du chômage
seule cette mesure avec d'autres
permettrait de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat nos concitoyens et d'améliorer
le sort des entreprises françaises
à cet égard les lycées vient de
confirmer les marges des entreprises
n'ont cessé de baisser c'est si vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les marges des
entreprises françaises sont les plus
faibles des 17 pays de la zone euro les
plus faibles
triste record pour la france enfin ceux
qui nous observent et attendre notre
redressement estime que nous réformes
sont un pas dans la bonne direction mais
qu'elles ne suffisent pas c'est parmi
d'autres le diagnostic que vient de
formuler la commission européenne et
dont vous devriez tenir compte monsieur
le ministre
par ailleurs pour équilibrer les grandes
public le matraquage fiscal a ses
limites
la question fondamentale est d'engager
le reflux des dépenses publiques je sais
bien que c'est votre détermination mais
il va falloir le démontrer
le gouvernement multiplie les
initiatives coûteuses ce matin en
commission des finances nous examinions
le projet de loi de refondation de
l'école de la république rétablissement
de scolarité à 2 jean création de 60000
postes d'enseignants et voilà quelques
mesures parmi d'autres nous attendons de
connaître le détail du moratoire des
normes les modalités d'abrogation des 35
heures
vos arbitrages pour réduire les dépenses
sociales votre réforme des retraites
la documentation précise des économies
que vous escomptez autant de mesures
indispensables dont vous ajourné la
concrétisation c'est malheureusement la
chronique d'un sinistre annoncé enfin
mes chers collègues je voudrais que l'on
évite à l'occasion de ce débat tout
réquisitoire anti européen
il est bien sûr toujours tentant dans
les circonstances aussi grave que celle
que nous traversons de transformer
l'europe en bouc émissaire aux fonds le
solde procès que nous pourrions faire à
l'europe et d'avoir permis à la france
de pratiquer aussi longtemps des
déficits aussi important sans sanction
le redressement incontournable et
certains engagements européens mais si
la france n'était pas dans la zone euro
elles seraient en situation calamiteuse
en situation catastrophique et ce sont
nos créanciers qui nous dicterait les
réformes sa accompli
dire combien de dévaluation
devrions-nous subir
quel serait alors le prix de l'énergie
le prix du carburant ce serait à n'en
point douter
l'explosion du chômage apocalypse now
pendant ce débat austérité et rigueur
sont les mots que le gouvernement oppose
souvent ne nous y trompons pas mes chers
collègues l'austérité n'est que la
sanction fatale du manque de rigueur
enfin monsieur le rapporteur général
vous escomptez beaucoup des propos de
monsieur barroso il ya ait rejeté avec
jean bizet à berlin nous avons rencontré
quelques responsables allemands
la tonalité était quelque peu différente
ne vous y trompez pas le programme de
stabilité nous engage comme tel il
devrait être légitimé par un vote au
parlement
je regrette amèrement le dédain
manifesté par le gouvernement à
l'encontre du sénat et plus encore la
docilité résigné de la majorité
sénatoriale face à ce que j'appelle une
maltraitance
en ces temps de crise dans cet ordre et
dans 6 et confiance en 70 comme si le
sénat n'était qu'une anomalie
démocratique c'est ça que vous voulez
dire mes chers collègues en ces temps de
crise de confiance
l' angoisse face à la mondialisation et
à l'avenir
l'angoissé perceptible le sénat devrait
être la chambre de la lucidité du
courage et de la sagesse l'espace sous
le jeu ce président s'il vous plaît un
peu de rigueur dans l'occupation nazie
dans l'espace où le jeu politicien
s'apaisent pour faire émerger des
propositions consensuelles supra
partisane
le lieu privilégié où rhône est espoir
et l'optimisme sur d'autres bases que
les chiffres fallacieux et des
conventions de langage
mes chers collègues il est de notre
responsabilité de démontrer
l'originalité et l'utilité de notre
haute assemblée je vous remercie bien
merci la parlotte à présent à monsieur
le président jacques mézard
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues s'il y
avait un vote nous voterions très
majoritairement pour ce qui nous est
présenté par le gouvernement
donc nous assumons nos choix et nous
avons l'habitude de le faire quelles que
soient les conséquences
quant au déni de réalité monsieur le
président arthuis vous savez ce n'est
pas l'apanage de ce gouvernement vous
l'avez rappelé très clairement et je
vous en remercie
c'est je dirais que six lits à déni de
réalité ce dont on n'est pas sûr en tout
cas nous serions plutôt dans la
continuité que dans le changement
monsieur le ministre du budget vous avez
posé quatre questions pour lesquelles
les réponses ressemblent pour un
ministre du budget certainement à la
quadrature du cercle
parce que c'est un exercice très
difficile
ce programme de stabilité est-ce qui ce
le cadre économique et financier pour
les années à venir
on notera au passage que les prévisions
macroéconomiques du programme de
stabilité pour les années 2013 2017 ont
sensiblement évolué par rapport à celles
de la loi de programmation qui était
nettement plus optimiste sur la rapidité
et l'ampleur de la reprise de l'activité
économique
mais à la différence de la loi de
programmation
le programme de stabilité sera transmis
à la commission européenne dans le cadre
du semestre européen et celle ci
publiera ses recommandations à la france
et aux autres états membres d'ici fin
mai ce programme a valeur de test de
crédibilité pour la france
et faut-il rappeler que notre pays il
faut le dire
faut-il rappeler que notre pays n'a pas
de très bons antécédents en la matière
de là aussi ce sera au moins une
continuité puisqu'il n'a jamais respecté
les programmes transmis à la commission
pas plus que les objectifs des diverses
lois de programmation
tous ces textes sont caractérisés par un
biais optimiste dans les prévisions
croissance alors qu'en est il des
prévisions de ce programme
difficile de prévoir moins que 0,1 de
croissance pour 2013 la croissance étant
déjà nul en 2012 une augmentation de 1,2
pour cent du pib en 2014 semble déjà
plus optimiste même si comme le précise
et le programme de stabilité cette
prévision repose notamment sur le fort
potentiel de rebond dont disposerait
l'économie française au sortir de la
crise il serait temps en effet après des
années de croissance atone et de
récession que l'économie rebondisse mais
comme l'a justement souligné le haut
conseil des finances publiques dont je
me plaît à souligner que chacun
reconnaît l'objectivité
si les prévisions macroéconomiques du
gouvernement sont en apparence très
proche de celle établie en février 2013
par la commission européenne
la similitude de prévision de taux de
croissance masque en effet en fait des
scénarios très différentes
aussi la commission retient telle une
hypothèse de déficit en hausse de 0,2
point en 2014 alors que le gouvernement
envisage une réduction de 0,8 point
il s'agit là d'une différence de taille
monsieur ministre qui peut susciter des
équipements des interrogations quant aux
prévisions de ce programme de stabilité
assez optimiste elle aussi concernant la
réduction du déficit effectif est
structurel quant aux prévisions à moyen
terme pour les années 2015 8 17
c'est à dire 2 % de croissance annuelle
bien que je ne souhaite pas être
pessimiste elles me paraissent
incertaines
notre taux de croissance potentiel
évalué un an et demi pour cent est en
réalité difficile à estimer aujourd'hui
divers facteurs pourrait en effet
conduire à réduire ce taux par rapport à
son niveau d'avant crise de nombreux
aléas entourent donc les prévisions du
gouvernement et font peser sur celle ci
un risque global à la baisse comme l'a
souligné le haut conseil
que pourra dire la commission européenne
sur ses prévisions
va-t-elle entendre les nombreuses voix
qui se sont justement élevées ces
derniers mois
y compris là où on les attendait le
moins comme au fmi contre les politiques
trop grand d'austérité menées en europe
qui pourrait avoir un impact néfaste et
irréversibles sur la croissance la
remise en cause récente des thèses des
économistes et américains rogoff et
reinhart affirmant qu une dette
supérieure à 90% du pib du pays avait
provoqué un effondrement de la
croissance devrait aussi conduire les
autres chantres de l'austérité arrêt
envisager très sérieusement les
priorités de politique économique pour
retrouver le chemin de la croissance
celui n'y serons nous avait dit que le
redressement des comptes publics et le
redressement productif sont les deux
faces d'une même médaille
il n'en existe pas moins une tension
entre la nécessité de réaliser des
économies sans précédent pour redresser
les comptes et celle de conduire des
réformes structurelles de grande ampleur
impliquant des investissements très
importants pour booster notre
compétitivité
c'est un équilibre très difficile à
trouver
crois qu'il existe des solutions tout
d'abord au niveau européen mais
d'ailleurs je remercie jean arthuis une
nouvelle fois d'avoir rappelé la
nécessité de saluer le travail avec
l'europe dans l'europe tout d'abord donc
au niveau européen on peut dégager trois
priorités desserrer les calendriers de
retour à l'est à l' équilibre financier
coordonnées véritablement les politiques
économiques et budgétaires pour garantir
une croissance partagée solidaire en
europe et enfin faire évoluer le rôle de
la bce
en effet le cours de l'euro est
clairement pour nous aujourd'hui à
handicap pour la compétitivité des
économies européennes et il est plus que
temps que la bce agit sans fin sur ce
front le positionnement aussi disons le
et égoïste et peu pragmatique de
l'allemagne devrait prendre fin il faut
qu'il soit de l'autre côté du rhin
lâcher du lest pour contribuer à
relancer la croissance en europe
vont ils mettre en place un salaire
minimum vont ils adopter une position
moins catégorique sur l'inflation le
gouvernement a déjà pris un certain
nombre d'initiatives très importantes
initiatives que très majoritairement
notre groupe a soutenu pour renforcer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
je pense aussi c'est je pense au projet
de loi sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
cependant nous sommes inquiet j'y viens
nous sommes inquiets à la lecture de
l'avis du haut conseil
lorsque celui ci considère que les
effets escomptés du 6 et gagnerait à
être davantage documenter une phrase
surtout me frappe dans cet avis la
résolution d handicap de compétitivité
prix hors prix des entreprises
françaises susceptibles d'améliorer les
parts de marchés à l'extérieur
n'apparaît pas acquise autrement dit le
plus dur reste à faire et il y faut du
temps monsieur le ministre il faut donc
pas se contenter de réforme déjà adoptée
et poursuivre des transformations
structurelles permettant de dynamiser
véritablement notre économie dans dix
ans dans 15 ans dans 20 ans c'est ce
qu'a réussi l'allemagne il y a quelques
années dans un contexte économique
différent avec une croissance européenne
élevés et un euro qui étaient autour de
0,9 un dollar la reconstitution ou le
renforcement de notre tissu industriel
de notre compétitivité ne se fera pas en
quelques mois les lois ressent allemagne
ont nécessité dix ans deux majorités
différentes
peut-être sera-t-il bon un jour de
méditer cet exemple mais la persévérance
du gouvernement dans la mise en oeuvre
des réformes annoncées notamment les 35
mesures du pacte pour la croissance la
compétitivité sera décisive la capacité
à faire apparaître la cohérence des
différentes réformes au service de
l'objectif général qu'est la relance de
la compétitivité et grâce à elle celle
de l'emploi et du niveau de vie l'est
tout autant
il y à monsieur le ministre et je
conclurai là dessus un déficit de
communication important quant aux
mesures adoptées par la majorité en
faveur des entreprises
elles sont encore trop méconnu sur le
territoire et les réformes aussi
pertinente soit elles ne serviront à
rien si elles ne sont pas accompagnées
par le retour de la confiance
sans la confiance de tous les acteurs
économiques dans notre économie dans
notre industrie nous ne pouvons réussir
alors pour créer un choc positif de
croissance commençons par réunir les
conditions d'un choc de conscience il
n'est plus temps de revenir sur le passé
il est temps de préparer l'avenir avec
un objectif ambitieux pour la france
dans l'euro à échéance de dix quinze ans
c'est peut-être ce qui manque dans ce
programme de stabilité programme que
notre groupe soutiens bien au delà de
ses grandes lignes et merci dans la
suite du débat la parole est à monsieur
jean vincent placé pour le groupe
écologie
on
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en vous
entendant à l'instance une ministre
parler de votre sérieux budgétaire je
n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de penser que si
l'ampleur des gels de crédits qui
s'annonce effectivement assez sérieuse
alerte sérieuse
il est difficile d'en dire autant des
prévisions qui la sous tendent
non du tout bien au contraire vos
hypothèses de croissance ont déjà été
maintes fois ausculté 0 1% cette année
un véhicule auto 2% l'année prochaine et
2% à partir de 2015
en effet des institutions si différentes
que le haut conseil des finances
publiques que vous avez vous même
installé le fmi ou le fc eux s'accordent
à considérer que ces prévisions sont
clairement affecté d'un dié trop
optimiste aux arguer du fait monsieur le
ministre que vos prévisions de
croissance ont calé sur celle de la
commission européenne certes mais les
scénarios la commission pour la
réduction du déficit ne sont pas les
mêmes loin s'en faut pour donner 1 2 de
croissance en 2014 elle se fonde elle
sur un déficit à 3,9 sont un point de
plus que le gouvernement bien au delà de
la barre convoité des 3% en matière de
déficits précisément et peut-être auriez
pu vous en souvenir vous n'étiez pas à
l'époque bien sûr le ministre du budget
mais j'avais interpellé monsieur mise à
l'économie il ya six mois il affirmé ici
avec la même force et la même technicité
que vous le fait que le déficit serait à
3% en 2013
j'avais parié malheureusement d'ailleurs
à cette même tribune que nous nous
retrouverions au printemps pour
constater ensemble qu'il n'en serait
rien dont acte
ce programme de stabilité entérine donc
un nouvel et allemands la trajectoire de
réduction du déficit
et cela nous ne pouvons d'ailleurs que
nous en réjouir des écologistes
jamais considéré le recours d ordonner à
l'endettement comme un modèle viable
mais pour autant la nécessaire
résorption du stock de dettes que nous
avons hérité des décennies de
capitalisme financier et un peu aussi de
toutes les majorités ne doit être
envisagée qu'avec plus dense sans
assommer les peuples ni au béret
l'économisme je vous accorde récents
peine que la france n'est pas la grèce
qui connaît depuis 2007 dans son chaos
social
une explosion des suicides des meurtres
et une dégradation de la santé publique
toutefois le programme de stabilité n'en
promet pas moins pour la prochaine loi
de finances 14 milliards de mesures
d'économie dont je ne sais s'il convient
de les qualifier de sérieuses au dos
terre 1,5 milliard seront retranchés la
dotation des collectivités
les dépenses de l'état seraient amputées
de 7,5 milliards sans que l'on sache
encore très bien d'ailleurs quels
seraient les administrations et services
publics qui seront les plus impactés
enfin 5 milliards seraient soustraits
aux dépenses sociales marquant notamment
le recul de la sécurité sociale au
profit les assurances complémentaires
retraites et santé
il nous semble d'autant moins urgent de
risquer ainsi le déclin économique et
sociale que le dogme de l'austérité plus
que jamais ces frites et se fissure
l'un de ses fondements scientifiques qui
postulait qu'un niveau de dette
supérieure à 90% entraîné un
effondrement mécanique la croissance
vient d'être démentie tout simplement
les auteurs de cette pénurie largement
diffusés utilisées au plus haut niveau y
compris sur ces bandes de tous bords il
faut le reconnaître ont reconnu que
presque tous bords ont reconnu des
erreurs invalidant leurs résultats ou
l'iran de plus en plus de pays en europe
du sud mais aussi du nord sans oublier
des états unis réclament des
trajectoires de consolidation budgétaire
beaucoup plus douce même le fmi s'est
exprimé en ce sens en france
plusieurs ministres et non des moindres
dont le ministre du redressement
productif et votre collègue monsieur le
ministre du budget votre collègue en
charge l'économie sociale solidaire et
la consommation ont récemment exprimé
leur souhait d'une inflexion la ligne
économique que vous défendez aujourd'hui
et c'est même un sentiment partagé sur
nombre de banques quand j'écoute
matinalement d excellente émission de
politique
alors pourquoi s'entêter
pourquoi persister affirmé chaque année
où chaque semestre
cette volonté d'airain ou de zinc de
réduire le déficit
une volonté que l'on sait d'emblée sapé
par les prévisions biaisées qui la sous
tendent une volonté dont les versions
précédentes ont pas trouvé à s'appliquer
une volonté dont le seul but consiste à
gagner le droit de demander un
commissaire européen
si l'on peut l'abandonner en chemin
c'est tout simplement absurde
le comble de cette vaste mascarade est
temps qu'elle vise à assurer notre
crédibilité a rassuré les marchés et la
même commission
d'ailleurs juniors c'est le commissaire
olli rehn est rassuré mais il semblerait
bien que les français qui subissent un
chômage endémique eux ne le soit pas
même le président barroso d'ailleurs
explique une politique de rigueur pour
être couronnés de succès doit recueillir
un minimum de soutien politique et
sociale force est de constater
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas tout à fait
le cas alors austérité rigueur sérieux
au fond peu importe la sémantique des
effets misme la communication voire le
marketing des simplement urgent de
rompre avec cette logique déjà
anachronique mais toujours délétère
issus de ce péché originel du
quinquennat que fut la ratification
immédiate du traité sont le re négocier
pour stopper l'hémorragie
rien ne pourra se substituer à davantage
d'intégration et d'harmonisation
européenne
c'est cela qu'il fallait négocier à la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale à la
mutualisation des dettes à
l'assouplissement
la politique monétaire pourquoi
continuer cette politique monétaire face
à une allemagne retranché il doit
comprendre qu'elle ne pourra de toute
façon pas prospérer dans une europe est
un peu qu'est ce que cela va donner
d'être la chancellière au milieu de ce
cimetière
la voix de la france est attendu et
espéré mais aussi la france elle peut
agir de façon autonome sur l'évasion
fiscale et sans qu'il soit besoin
d'attendre l'opportunité de nouveaux
scandales de nombreuses mesures comme
une loi fatca peuvent être mises en
oeuvre pour faire bouger les lignes
européennes ainsi que nous l'avons fait
d'ailleurs avec le ministre de
l'économie et des finances pour la
transparence bancaire sur laquelle nous
avons travaillé de concert et je m'en
réjouis
il n'est pas non plus trop tard pour
mettre sur pied la grande réforme
fiscale qu'on nous avait promise pour
dégager des économies d'échelle par une
réforme territoriale ambitieuse ce qui
est loin d'être le cas quand on voit les
textes qu'on nous présente pour arrêter
les projets d'aménagement pharaonique
lorsqu'ils sont aussi sonné onéreux que
nuisible ni pour mettre au jour des
marges de manoeuvre budgétaires sur la
force de frappe nucléaire aérienne un
pur gadget dépourvue d'enjeux
stratégiques et tout cela on a pensé
aujourd'hui qu'il fallait donner comme
message même pas au peuple de gauche au
peuple de france qu'il fallait faire des
efforts sur l'emploi sur l'école sont
les hôpitaux en sanctuarisant le budget
militaire
et bien mes chers collègues j'espère que
quand on fermera les hôpitaux les écoles
on commencera par les circonscriptions
des parlementaires si attachés à cette
force de frappe qui ne servent à rien
qui ne sert à rien rés
bien sûr pour préparer une économie
durable plutôt que de couper à la hache
dans les dépenses publiques
il serait indispensable d'instaurer
enfin une véritable fiscalité écologique
redistributive promise par le
gouvernement et d'adapter notre appareil
productif et industriel aux besoins et
enjeux de demain notamment énergétique
par exemple
par exemple en conditionnant c'est
invraisemblable niches fiscales niches
fiscales supplémentaires qu'on le
veuille ou pas c'est une niche fiscale
d'un point de pib qui est le cicr en ces
temps incertains parfois troubler la
gauche au pouvoir est une chance une
chance pour la concorde civile
oui mais de ce banc là une chance pour
la concorde civile et de toute façon il
n'y aura pas de comparaison quelques
puis c'est très critique par rapport à
ce que nous avons suivis pendant votre
cas qu'elle a une chance
une chance pour la concorde civile une
chance pour les plus fragiles une chance
pour notre environnement oui cette
gauche au pouvoir doit être une chance
nous ne pouvons pas laisser la gauche se
morfondre dans l'illusion défraîchi des
annonces entendu nous ne pouvons pas la
laisser la gauche errer dans les
décombres d'un modèle libéral
productiviste moribond mais toujours
dangereux nous ne pouvons pas laisser la
gauche s'engourdir de l'exercice
gestionnaire du pouvoir et oublier ceux
qui souffrent la gauche au pouvoir est
une chance à la condition qu'elle soit
une audace une audace écologique
une audace sociale une audace
démocratique
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
et madame des esgaulx vous me demandez
si nous allons voter vous savez tout non
loin du tout conclut occasion
chers collègues et je vais conclure je
vais conclure et je vais vous répondre
car vous savez je ne fuis pas mes
responsabilités je suis plutôt connu
pour cela le gouvernement n'a pas jugé
indispensable de sanctionner notre débat
par un vote mais vous aurez compris que
si le groupe écologiste avait pu
s'exprimer ainsi en ma voix est en ma
parole
le vote n'aurait pas été favorable dans
la suite du débat la parole est
maintenant à madame marie hélène des
esgaulx pour le groupe ump
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais faire mon
intervention en deux temps je voudrais
d'abord répondre à monsieur le ministre
du budget parce que il a voulu nous
expliquer la vérité des chiffres
tout à l'heure il a peu parlé finalement
du programme de stabilité il a essayé de
deux je dirais est tronquée comme
d'habitude le débat opposant s'endorment
de questions ayant 10 ans ça donne deux
choses la vérité des chiffres
monsieur le ministre elle est relative
selon la manière dont on les présente
je voudrais donc entrer dans le détail
des chiffres vous nous dites que
l'augmentation des dépenses est moindre
en 2012 par rapport à la période 2007
2012 et la période 2002 2007 avant 2007
et avoir la crise je vous le concède aux
dépenses publiques étaient trop élevés
pendant de nombreuses années nous avons
tous été co responsable d'un manque de
vertu budgétaire mais suite à la crise
l'effort sur les dépenses a été sans
précédent et il est pernicieux de
comparer l'évolution des dépenses entre
une année l'année 2012 et une période de
cinq ans sans entrer dans les détails de
celle ci oui nos dépenses ont augmenté
plus fortement dans cette période parce
que nous avons subi la crise en 2008
cette crise a nécessité en urgence un
plan de relance qui a été saluée par
tous les commentateurs internationaux
pour son efficacité et qui a permis à la
france de mieux s'en sortir que
l'allemagne nos dépenses publiques ont
alors bondi de 53,3 % du pib en 2008 à
56,2 8% en 2009 mais par la suite elles
ont sans cesse diminué sauf en 2012
suite à votre arrivée au pouvoir
quatre mois au bout de quatre mois de
l'année 2012 où les dépenses ont de
nouveau augmenté de 50 5,9 pour cent en
2011 à 56,6 pour ça en 2012 soit le même
niveau
aux commandes du plan de relance la
france se situe au deuxième rang de l'os
et des oeufs en matière de niveau de
dépenses publiques
vous parlez d'une baisse historique des
dépenses de l'état en 2012
mais vous oubliez que c'est faux la
première fois depuis 1945 que les
dépenses de l'état hors dette et
pensions ont diminué en valeur
c'est en 2011 le déficit budgétaire de
l'état avaient alors diminué de 36% et
s'était établi puisqu'il faut parler de
chiffres à 95,3 milliards d'euros contre
148,8 milliards en 2010 ainsi dès 2011
les dépenses ont été réduites de plus de
260 millions d'euros et les économies
affectés au désendettement
la charge de la dette a été ainsi révisé
à la baisse de 700 millions d'euros et
de la même manière c'est en 2010 que
pour la première fois de la décennie
l'ondam a été respecté alors quand vous
voulez parler de chiffres incontestables
seul ministre il faut y aller 1
alors que le niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires avait été maintenue entre
42 et 44 % du pib sous le quinquennat
précédent malgré la crise
celui ci explose en 2013 avec l'arrivée
de françois hollande avec près de 45 %
et ils devraient atteindre le taux
record de 46 3% en 2013
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance pour
en savoir plus ou pour revoir cette
séance consacrée à la déclaration du
gouvernement sur le programme de
stabilité
notre site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
fin de journée à tous